das ganze Thema
Migration die Frage des europäischen
Asylsystems soll jetzt ein weiteres Mal
die Frage an Robin Alexander
diskutiert und dann endlich die
Nacht schon eine europäische Lösung
gefunden werden nach der wir so lange
suchen was macht sie
möglicherweise Glauben Alexander dass es
diesmal endlich gelingt ich habe einen
Eindruck dass gerade sehr viele
Positionen teils auch sehr ideologische
Position dass die gerade fallen geht
ihnen das auch so auf allen Seiten ja
also ich glaube die
beschriebenen Dinge also dass man sieht
dass Diktatoren Flüchtlinge ja richtig
anfliegen und diese Leute hier in der
polnischen Grenze waren die sind ja
nicht hätten ja gar nicht den Weg über
Weißrussland genommen unter Normal die
wir angeworben worden um dieses
auszulösen oder auch was Erdogan in der
Zwischenzeit versucht hat auch Erde und
hat Flüchtlinge in Bewegung gesetzt um
Druck zu machen auf die EU oder
spanien hatte diese Erfahrung mit
Marokko gemacht also dass man sieht dass
man da verletzlich ist und natürlich
sieht man auch dass die große
Fluchtbewegung auf der aus der Ukraine
ja in Europa super super bearbeitet
wurde also es gab ja gar keine große
Debatte nehmen wir die Ukraine oder
nicht sondern wir haben die alle
genommen und nicht nur wir auch die viel
gescholtenden Polen und andere Europäer
ja und das Europa jetzt sagt wo wir
sehen wir nehmen so viele auf können wir
das andere nicht etwas besser ordnen
ich finde da darf man wirklich das finde
ich eine sehr plausible Überlegung
die Frage ist wie wir es jetzt machen
ich meine ihr seid deswegen habe ich
vorhin auch gerade noch mal ihr Buch
erwähnt ne die getriebenen von 2015
die Debatte ist exakt die die wir schon
mal hatten dann ging die Zahlen ein
bisschen runter und jetzt gehen die
Zahlen plötzlich wieder dramatisch nach
oben
wo stehen wir da im Moment ist die Zahl
korrekt die von zitiert habe dass wir
möglicherweise 4 500.000 je nachdem wie
man hört Menschen zusätzlich in dieses
Land kriegen werden in diesem Jahr wovon
gehen sie aus also wir haben jetzt
zahlen aktuell von Januar bis April
haben wir 100000 Erstanträge nur in
Deutschland wir hatten Zahlen letztes
Jahr für die gesamte Europäische Union
ungefähr 900.000 Asus Suchende sind zu
uns gekommen 900.000 und jetzt liegen
wir in den ersten vier Monaten bei
100.000 und es ist davon auszugehen
jetzt wo das Wetter wieder wärmer wird
dadurch dass die Zahlen gegen Sommer
immer steigen bis Herbst dass diese Zahl
von 400.000 so
nicht ganz aus der Luft gegriffen ist
also ich halte sie durchaus für
realistisch und dann müssen wir uns
natürlich Gedanken machen in Wahrheit
wir erstens zulassen dass das Booten
Diktatoren autokarten Menschen als Waffe
einsetzen knicken wir ein und sagen okay
jeder ist willkommen der als Waffe
eingesetzt wird wo führt das hin werden
diese Menschen nicht weiter benutzt von
Diktatoren um die Gesellschaft von innen
zu springen diese Frage muss man sich
ernsthaft stellen oder sagen wir wir
ziehen klare Regeln auf wir ziehen auch
klare Linien auf und versuchen gerade
was die Migration außerhalb der Ukraine
betrifft die ja letztes Jahr auch
immerhin bei 220.000 in Deutschland
alleine
traf
versuchen darf es wirklich zuordnen
insofern ist das ein guter Versuch was
die Europäische Kommission oder ein
gutes Papier was die Europäische
Kommission da vorgelegt hat und wenn man
jetzt aber hört dass sich die
EU-Botschafter in vielen nach Humor
nicht einig sind und das ganze die große
Entscheidung auf morgen vertagt hat
jetzt schon von einer Sondersitzung in
zwei Wochen noch mal die Rede ist
schwindet meine Hoffnung oder in anderen
Worten bin ich nicht so optimistisch
wieder Kanzler das morgen tatsächlich
eine Einigung erzählt werden kann gerade
was das Thema asylaußenzentren betrifft
was zwar nur ein Tropfen auf dem heißen
Stein wäre aber eine richtige Richtung
einschlagen würde um tatsächlich zu
einer gemeinsamen zu einem gemeinsamen
System zu einer gemeinsamen Lösung zu
kommen
lass uns doch ganz konkret rein also was
in Rede steht und das einmal kurz
erklären Herr Alexander sind unter
anderem Asylverfahren direkt an den
europäischen Außengrenzen genau wie soll
das gehen also dazu muss man erstmal
wissen
das soll nicht alle machen dort sondern
nur Leute aus Ländern die eine ganz
geringe Anerkennungsquote haben also
nehmen wir mal so den typischen den man
so kennt der wäre gar kein Fall dafür
weil die Syrer haben eine sehr hohe
Anerkennungsquote für die würde sich gar
nichts ändern es gibt aber Länder wie
nehmen wir Bangladesch die haben eine
Anerkennungsquote von deutlich unter 20
Prozent und auch diese Leute würden
nicht abgewiesen sondern die würden in
diesen Zentren ein Verfahren bekommen
und wenn sie angenommen werden würden
sie so ist das Ideal typisch geplant
dann in ein Land verteilt und eben Asyl
genießen und wenn sie nicht angenommen
werden würden sie zurückgebracht so es
geht also nur um diese Gruppe aus wo
wohin das Land wo sie herkommen
die Frage ist genau richtig funktioniert
aber so ist dieses System gedacht und
der der sozusagen der der Vorteil den
richtigen EU-Kommission davon verspricht
ist dass man eben nicht diese Bewegung
durch Europa hat das jemand also über
Italien
Österreich aber uns landet sondern dass
das Verfahren an in Italien gemacht wird
das ist noch mal konkret sie dürfen
sofort gratulieren noch mal konkret also
an der EU-Außengrenze wo also auf
griechischem Territorium genau das
sollen die auf Italienisch
EU-Länder an der ostengrenze durchführen
jetzt ist die Diskussion ob andere
EU-Staaten da z.B personell finanziell
unterstützen was dann was das Verfahren
in diesen Asylzentren betrifft das ist
jetzt die große Frage wir werden morgen
gemeinsam erfahren ob das funktioniert
oder nicht oder wer von den anderen
EU-Mitgliedstaaten sich bereit erklärt
Deutschland hat schon signalisiert wir
würden uns auch personell beteiligen
damit das in den Asylzentren
funktioniert die schutzquote darf nicht
über 20% liegen das ist das von wovon
gerade Robin Alexander gesprochen hat
das heißt beispielsweise die Türkei so
die Türkei ist gerade bei uns das dritte
stärkste das drittgrößt also das dritte
Herkunftsland und hat zehn
Herkunftsländern die seit Januar bis
April wieder diese Statistik zu uns
gekommen sind ist Syrien nach wie vor an
erster Stelle danach kommt Afghanistan
danach kommt die Türkei die Türkei hat
aber eine schutzquote von 16 Prozent das
heißt alle Türken würden in Zukunft an
diese Außengrenze ihr Verfahren oder die
bei den Türken würde dieses Verfahren an
der Außengrenze ablaufen und zwar in
einer Zeit von drei Monaten so ist der
Plan länger als drei Monaten dass dieses
Verfahren nicht laufen weil wir ja von
beschleunigten Asylverfahren sprechen
wichtiger Punkt ausgenommen sind alle
Familien mit Kindern und der Streitpunkt
ist der Streitpunkt ist Deutschland
besteht darauf dass die Kinder
also das alle Familien die Kinder 18
also Minderjährige und Frankreich oder
Polen bestehen darauf dass die Kinder
unter 12 sind damit sie als Ausnahme
gelten also insofern gibt es da im
Moment eine breite Diskussion darüber
wer alles von diesen beschleunigten
Verfahren an der Außengrenze ausgenommen
werden soll Porträt sie wollten gerade
ja
weil so vieles da dran falsch ist also
erstens
der gerade auf dem Tisch liegt weil in
der Theorie wird das alles so besprochen
als würde es dazu führen dass wir
schnellere Verfahren an den Grenzen
hätten an den EU-Außengrenzen hätten ähm
man dann in der Situation wäre die Leute
zu verteilen alles wäre besser und wir
hätten irgendwie eine bessere Situation
klingt alles sehr fluffiger
in der Realität ganz anders vor und die
Realität ist ja eine andere also erstens
geht's nicht nur um die Frage ob man die
Person dann wieder zurückführt in die
Herkunftsländer was konkret diskutiert
wird auch im europäischen Rahmen ist ob
man auch Verträge und Vereinbarung macht
mit Ländern ähnlich wie beispielsweise
Großbritannien ist mit Ruanda getan hat
also Drittstaaten die gar nichts mit der
Situation zu tun haben und ob man dafür
auch eine finanzielle Belohnung bekommt
als Staat wenn man sagt ich möchte keine
Leute aufnehmen so muss man einmal ganz
kurz einmal kurz erklären also jetzt
gehen Sachen durcheinander ursprüngliche
Vorschlag der schwedischen Kommissarin
einer Sozialdemokratin ist das was Frau
Bühler gerade erklärt hat und heute die
treffen sich am Morgen hat eine
Staatengruppe das vorgeschlagen was sie
jetzt sagen dass man also nicht in
diesem Zentrum an der EU Außengrenze das
Verfahren macht sondern in einem dritten
Land und das ist in der Tat interessant
weil damit experimentieren ja gerade die
Briten indemander ich könnte mir aber
vorstellen dass dieser Vorschlag so spät
kommt und so erkennbar keine Mehrheit
finden kann dass da politisch der
Bundesregierung etwas entgegengekommen
wird das nämlich Frau bärburg sagen kann
sie hat die Ruanda Lösung verhindert und
die außengrenzenlösung die Frau Güller
eben geschildert hat dann durchgewunken
dann lass uns das noch einmal ganz kurz
damit wirklich jeder versteht weil es
interessant ist also diese Ruanda Lösung
sondern nicht das jetzt einfach mal so
nennen die das glaube ich auch Teilen
heute auf den Tisch und würde bedeuten
sie sagten gerade die die Briten haben
das versucht ja die Briten sagen
Menschen kommen sozusagen illegal ins
Land das ist die Idee und dann machen
wir das Verfahren nicht in England
sondern wir schicken Sie mit dem
Flugzeug nach Ruanda ist völlig egal wer
da drin sitzt sind auch nicht Menschen
aus Ruanda sondern es gibt einfach ein
Abkommen mit Ruanda die kriegen Geld
dafür und die werden einfach
zurückgeflogen nach Ruanda die Dänen
haben auch solche Ideen
Australia haben auch mit so etwas schon
länger gearbeitet ich persönlich kann es
mir relativ schwierig für die EU
vorstellen ehrlich gesagt deshalb glaube
ich dass er sein politischer Vorschlag
ist um der Bundesregierung die dann
sagen das abzuräumen um dann in
sozusagen den Vorschlag der Mitte
zuzustimmen okay auch noch mal ganz
Ruanda Modell sagen sie Frau auf gar
keinen Fall nein es kommt nicht in die
Tüte genau und was ich auch also ich
glaube was man vorweg sagen muss ich
glaube es ist absolut richtig dass ein
europäische Lösung gibt mit Blick auf
die asylsituation und auch auf mit Blick
darauf dass viele Staaten gerade die
Mittelmeer Anrainerstaaten maximal
überfordert sind wir haben in den
letzten Jahren mehrmals darüber
gesprochen wie dramatisch die Situation
sind und dass da teilweise
Menschenrechtsverletzungen stattfinden
die wir nicht tolerieren können eben
gerade wurde das Beispiel genannt wie
auch beispielsweise Russland ist ganz
krass benutzt als spalt-thema in
europäischen Union und da ist doch die
Frage ganz klar wie verhalten uns in
dieser Frage und die unterschiedlichen
Vorschläge die auf dem Tisch liegen die
zu einer Verschärfung an den
europäischen Außengrenzen führen könnte
die dazu führen könnten dass viele
Menschen inhaftiert werden in
Massenlagern ich finde das ist eine
Frage die hochproblematisch ist und es
gibt viele Menschenrechtsorganisation
die genau dieses Szenario sehen dass das
kommen könnte so ich finde es auch
schwierig in einer Situation in der wir
das Asylrecht
oder auch der Anspruch überhaupt Schutz
zu suchen steigt man immer wieder in die
Situation kommt sich die Frage zu
stellen wollen wir es an der Stelle
begrenzen und ich glaube das ist die
Wiederholung von Debatten die wir in den
letzten Jahren immer wieder hatten und
auch wenn man zurückblickt immer wieder
hat okay aber es geht nicht darum zwei
verschiedene Dinge es geht ja nicht
darum Schutz zu begrenzen das ist ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt denn alle die dort
ihren Antrag stellen und wo klargestellt
festgestellt wird die sind
schutzberechtigt die dürfen ja kommen es
geht nicht darum Schutz zu begrenzen es
geht darum
illegale Migration das heißt diejenigen
die nicht schutzberechtigt sind das zu
begrenzen und das klingt wenn man sagt
Schutz zu begrenzen klingt das verdammt
hat das ist aber gar nicht der Punkt das
ist auch nicht der Punkt über den sich
die Europäische Kommission im Moment
unterhält also ich glaube das ist
wichtig dass die Frage Zahlen zu
begrenzen Migration zu begrenzen
und die Frage ist mit welchen Mitteln
welchen Maßnahmen soll das stattfinden
und diese Frage ist hochkonfliktiv weil
eben auch die eu-anrainerstaaten ganz
deutlich sagen die Vorschläge die auch
auf dem Tisch sind die fühlen 0 zu einer
Entlastung für uns also das haben wir
auf der einen Seite und auf der anderen
Seite eine relevanter Punkt der auch uns
als Deutschland immer wieder wichtig war
war dass wir dann auch verpflichtende
verteilungsquoten brauchen auf die
Europäische Union so und diese Situation
man wird sehen was morgen diskutiert
wird es sieht nicht so aus als würde
diese Frage auch kommen ich glaube die
Frage von all diese Punkte
zusammenzudenken und da eine Lösung für
zu finden das sieht gerade nicht so aus
als würden europäische Einigung bei
dieser Frage geben aber
solidaritätsmechanismus darum geht es
morgen auch und dann ist natürlich die
Verteilungsfrage ganz entscheidende aber
das ist mit auf dem Tisch aber
haben dass viele Staaten sagen wir
werden diese verteidigen Mechanismus
verpflichtend nicht mitmachen das sagen
die ganz offen und ehrlich
verpflichtenden Mechanismus geben wird
dann werden wir das nicht mitmachen die
Anrainer starten sagen bei solchen die
wir dann finden würden an den
Außengrenzen bedeutet das eine
Mehrbelastung für uns an der Stelle das
heißt ich wünsche mir an allererster
Stelle des europäischen Einigung gibt
aber nicht zu dem Preis dass man keine
Einigung findet die wir auch politisch
immer wieder gefordert haben die eben
human ist und die eben sich durchaus mit
der Frage auseinandersetzt
verpflichtende verteilquoten zu haben im
Interesse der Anrainerstaaten aber auch
im Interesse der Menschen damit sie eben
nicht in überfüllten Lagern an den
EU-Außengrenzen sind
lass uns doch eins nach dem anderen mal
versuchen ein bisschen zuordnen
Obergrenzen ist das andere Thema sie
sagen natürlich geht's darum eine eine
wie auch immer geartete Obergrenze
einzuziehen sie sagen einfach illegale
irreguläre Migration zu beenden
Alexander wie soll das konkret laufen
Frau Teresa sagte gerade das war
interessant vor ein paar Minuten viele
Begriff Haft sind drin Haft also hat
Bedingungen
für sie ist das ein riesen Knast der da
gebaut werden soll wie soll das konkret
laufen also da gibt es jetzt ein Land
wie Italien da gibt es ein Land wie
Griechenland dort direkt an der Grenze
sollen diese beschleunigten Verfahren
stattfinden wir haben gerade gehört das
soll ungefähr in drei Monaten über die
Bühne gehen schneller geht es offenbar
nicht das heißt in diesen drei Monaten
passiert was wo sind all diese Leute die
werden festgehalten
und das problematische ist dass er 2015
haben etwas ähnliches die Ungarn gemacht
also die Ungarn sehr gerügt worden von
der EU und die Ungarn und immer gesagt
das ist ja kein keine Haftanstalt weil
die Leute können ja wieder gehen nur
eben aus dem Land raus aber halt in eine
Richtung nur man muss aber sich ehrlich
machen dass wir in Deutschland am
Frankfurter Flughafen schon mit einem
ähnlichen rechtlichen Konstrukt arbeiten
das ist ja
Deutschland keine EU-Außengrenze
aber es können Leute einfliegen so und
an der einzigen Stelle wo die Leute
einfliegen können machen wir schon so
einfach fahren wie Frau Touré jetzt
skandalisieren würde für die Grenzregion
maximal 19 Tage und auf der anderen
Seite finde ich es schon berechtigt weil
das jetzt irgendwie nicht
skandalisierend ist sondern einfach die
Beschreibung der Realität ich finde es
unmöglich zu tun genau also ich finde es
unmöglich und ich finde es
menschenrechtlich bedenklich wenn wir
Menschen inhaftieren an den europäischen
Außengrenzen die Monate lang in solchen
Lagern dann wären und dann erst die
Situation haben dass sie möglicherweise
ist noch Null sicher dass das
tatsächlich eine Verteilung dann
stattfindet und ich finde das ist eine
Debatte ist die man definitiv führen
muss dass man sich ehrlich machen muss
wenn man einem solchen Vorschlag
sozusagen
seit vier Jahren geführt wird
und die eigentliche Neuerung daher die
neue Positionierung der Ampel ja weil
bisher dachte man die Ampel ist dagegen
also vor allen Dingen die Grüne Partei
und dann kam die aus einem
Koalitionsausschuss mit Olaf Scholz und
sagten nee wir sind jetzt auch dafür und
das das ist das eigentlich bemerkenswert
so aber ich möchte das nicht kritisieren
weil ich finde dass diese Überlegungen
auch bei grünen Leuten richtig sind und
man die auch würdigen muss was ist was
ist der grüne Vorschlag was ist
sozusagen die
gesichtswaren der Lösung für für die
Grüne Partei
die Grünen haben in den letzten Wochen
weil es innerparteilich eine auffallung
dagegen gab gelegt und haben das was
glaube gerade schon gesagt hat an den
alltagsgrenzen zu arbeiten und nicht mit
Familien und so weiter aber den Grünen
fällt das so schwer dieses Prinzip
dieser Anstalten an den Außengrenzen
dem zuzustimmen weil das in Deutschland
mal von Horst Seehofer in die Debatte
gebracht wurde und da haben die Grünen
doch das war der Vorschlag von Horst
Seehofer in der großen Koalition der
arbeitet wurde von Staatssekretär
Teichmann und der ist das ist es de
facto ist dass das gleiche System nur
jetzt haben sich eben in Europa eine
Menge Leute auch aus anderen politischen
Familien darauf geeinigt und jetzt
müssen die Grünen halt darüber springen
dass sie damals Seehofer so verteufelt
haben aber das sollten Sie tun und jetzt
noch mal was ist sozusagen die die Idee
die gesichtswarende Lösung für die
Grünen hat die dann zu tun mit den
Kindern dass man sagt das gilt für
Erwachsene warum mit Erwachsenen so aber
Kinder sind davon aus wir wissen gar
nicht minderjährige sind davon
ausgegangen
also bis 18 sind sie ausgenommen das
heißt du kommst jetzt als Familie dort
an aber das ist doch nicht
verstehen kommst dort an in dieses
Zentrum und kannst dann dein Kind über
die Grenze schicken
weil die die zuständigen Ministerinnen
sind der Frau Faeser und Frau bärbock
also zwischen denen die sind natürlich
verhandeln für Deutschland vor Caesar
aber vor Werbung muss zustimmen und dann
gab es diesen Koalitionsausschuss bei
Olaf Scholz und dann kam raus und dann
gab sie diese Positionsänderung das
hoffe er sagt plötzlich sagte wir sind
auch dafür wo alle gestaunt haben und
seitdem ist durchgesickert dass es schon
noch Einwände gibt zum Beispiel die
schutzquote das 20% aus einem Land
anerkannt er nicht anerkannt werden
müssen damit die überhaupt in diese
Verfahren kommen die wollen die Grünen
auch 15 % senken und sie haben auch die
Idee wenn so eine Anstalt völlig
überlastet ist senkt man die noch weiter
also auf 5 % umso griechische Zustände
vermeiden und sie haben das wie eben mit
den Altersgrenzen aber das sind wenn man
einmal das System anerkannt hat also
glaube ich hat man wirklich eine Politik
Änderung gemacht aber nochmal wissen
noch mal verstehen also da kommt jetzt
eine Familie mit minderjährigen Kindern
an die ist vom Verfahren ausgeschlossen
also die
genau die macht das andere das ist ja
genau der Kernpunkt dieser Debatte also
in dem Papier da Kommission also genau
die Kommission hat ja selbst den
Vorschlag gemacht Familien mit Kinder
bis zu 12 Jahren sind ausgeschlossen das
ist der Vorschlag der Kommission aber
die Farbe Länder jetzt haben Anrainer
Länder Italien Griechenland Zypern Malta
Spanien gesagt nein Altersgrenze bei
Kindern müsste auf 18 angehoben werden
weil sie somit nicht mehr zuständig sind
in diesen Asylzentren bei dem
beschleunigten Verfahren für diese
Familien mit Kindern und jetzt geht es
auch noch um Minderjährige wenn ein
15-Jähriger da alleine auftaucht was wir
aus der Erfahrung
15 2 16 wissen was wirklich keine
Seltenheit ist das Familien ihre Kinder
in ihre minderjährigen vorgeschickt
haben dann soll er auch also das Kind
dieser 15-jährige auch ausgeschlossen
werden und er sagt ich nein der Kommis
der Kommissionsvorschlag mit 12 war
richtiger in dem Falle weil wir auf der
anderen Seite wieder ganz viele Familien
haben werden die das Kind alleine auf
diese gefährliche Reise schicken und
diese gefährliche Reise ist ja vor allem
bis zur EU-Außengrenze und da Sachen die
Grünen Annalena Werbung auch die
Familienministerin nein die Altersgrenze
muss bis 18 angehoben werden ich hatte
es von falschen Vorschlag
ja ich bin fassungslos wenn man sowas
sagt weil wir sprechen über eine
Situation an den Grenzen wo wir
möglicherweise davon ausgehen dass
überfüllte Lager stattfinden die
Bedingungen die teilweise jetzt schon
beschrieben werden die Situation die wir
heute schon beschrieben bekommen dass
pushbacks stattfinden all diese Fragen
die gerade diskutiert werden die höchst
problematisch sind wir haben teilweise
Situationen in Deutschland in
Dublin-Verfahren dass Menschen hier
ankommen aus Griechenland und man sagt
die Situation ist dort so unwürdig dass
wir dort Leute nicht wieder
zurückschicken können im Rahmen des
dublin-verfahrens und ich finde es nicht
normal zu diskutieren ob das in Ordnung
ist unter 18-Jährige bis 12 Uhr oder
sonstiges in solchen Lagern zu
inhaftieren und das ist genau der Grund
auch warum wir diese Debatte auch
innerhalb der Parteien natürlich auch
Details zu gehen weil dann versteht man
plötzlich was da eigentlich gerade
passiert und warum es da wirklich geht
welche auch ideologischen Positionen im
Zweifel geräumt werden müssen ich würde
zum Beispiel bei dem Punkt anfangen dass
ich nicht finde das ist eine
ideologische Position drin ist ich finde
es geht um die Frage und das ist ja auch
genau die Position die beispielsweise
dieser Paus ganz deutlich dann vertreten
hat das ist hier um die Frage von
kinderrechtskonventionen geht das kann
man als ideologisch abtun zu sagen ich
finde das problematisch aber ich
persönlich finde dass es eine absolut
berechtigte Diskussion ist und
Diskussion ist doch nicht ob man den
Kindern was Gutes oder Böses will das
Problem ist doch wenn man bestimmte
Regeln Regeln aus besten Wissen und
Gewissen meinetwegen aufstellt dadurch
aber ein Anreiz baut Minderjährige auf
diese Reise zu schicken da hat man doch
etwas erreicht
zwischen Verantwortung
Konflikt zwischen Verantwortung
gewissensethik
wenn wir den Leuten sagen wenn ihr vor
Krieg oder Vertreibung flieht und wir
möchten das aber eigentlich nicht dass
sie ankommt in der Europäischen Union
dann schrecken wir euch damit anfangen
eine Million Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine sind gerade gekommen ja wir
haben den Krieg gesehen die Leute sind
da und es gibt noch nicht mal bei uns
eine gesellschaftliche Debatte ob wir
die nicht wollen so und jetzt geht es
darum die Leute die darüber hinauskommen
und auch da und die Leute die ein
absehbaren Schutz bekommen sollen gar
nicht in dieses System reinkommen
es geht nur um die keine irre ja also es
geht um die Leute die wahrscheinlich
keinen Anspruch auf Asyl haben
so und ich finde das müssen sie immer
noch nicht sagen dass es alles richtig
aber das sollten sie anerkennen dass man
auf diesem Niveau diskutiert auch auf
diesem moralischen Niveau das sollten
Sie auch der Gegenseite zugestehen also
das wird gerade deshalb so moralisch
weil das Argument war ja vorhin wir
stecken Kriegsflüchtlinge vertriebene in
diese Lager Robin alexander hat es
gerade genau richtig beschrieben die
sind genau ausgeschlossen wenn man das
Wort an dieser Stelle vielleicht einfach
mal kurz erwähnen darf das sind
hauptsächlich Menschen die ihren
wirtschaftlichen Elend entfliehen wollen
ich habe da menschlich absolutes
Verständnis
völlig nachvollziehen das bedeutet aber
nicht dass sie schutzberechtigt nach
Artikel 16A oder nach der Genfer
Flüchtlingskonvention
Flüchtlingskonvention stehen
Menschen die ihren wirtschaftlichen
Elend entgehen wollen genießen in Europa
das steht dann nicht das stimmt
das glaube ich auch da schon trennen ein
Asylrecht und ein Antrag zu stellen und
ich kann die Frage ist absolut relevant
und selbst wenn wir in der Situation es
geht ich glaube und das ist das was ich
so problematisch und der Debatte ganz
oft finde selbst wenn es Menschen sind
die möglicherweise kein Anrecht auf Asyl
haben und diese Debatte muss man offen
führen da da versperren wir uns Null als
grüne dafür sperre ich mich auch nicht
aber warum zur Hölle soll ich eigentlich
einen Unterschied machen wie ich die
menschenrechtlichen Bedingungen für
Menschen unterteile ich meine selbst
wenn wir in die Situation kommen dass
Menschen nicht das Anrecht darauf haben
hier zu bleiben und zurückgeführt werden
müssen weil das kann immer am Ende eines
rechtsstaatlichen Verfahren stehen da
kann ich doch trotzdem politisch dafür
einstehen zu sagen dass ich finde auch
die müssen unter humanenbedingungen
in dieser Runde hätte ihn da
widersprochen ich sage einfach nur dass
die Vorschläge die gerade auf
Europäischer Union und Ebene diskutiert
werden von vielen Seiten bekämpft werden
aus der eigenen Perspektive starten weil
sie sagen sie sind eh schon überfordert
andere die sagen helfen kann
verteilmechanismus bei uns und die
Bedingungen das sozusagen diese
Haftzentren vor Ort da sein sollen wird
kritisch diskutiert übrigens auch
komplett in einer Partei und das ist
eine Haltung die wir an dieser Stelle
haben ihre Partei hat den
Koalitionsausschuss zugestimmt genau und
wir sind trotzdem in der Situation dass
wir diese Debatte führen und das gehört
sich auch für uns als Partei diese
Debatten zu führen weil wir eben ein
Koalitionsvertrag haben
sie denken Konferenz hat sich in der
letzten Sitzung wo es um das Thema
Flüchtlinge geht auch mit diesem Thema
Außengrenzen beschäftigt und die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz hat
festgehalten das beschleunigte Verfahren
an der europäischen Außengrenze
stattfinden sollen ich möchte sagen
gehörte auch ein quatschmann und dazu
gehört auch ein Daniel Günther ja aber
kein einziges Bundesland nein das müssen
sie überhaupt keine Frage das müssen sie
wirklich nicht aber es ist nicht nur
eine alleinige Entscheidung der Grünen
alleine aber nur kurz sagen das ist
keine alleinige Entscheidung der Grünen
auf Bundesebene sondern auch der einzige
grüne Ministerpräsident hat dem
zugestimmt es gibt keine Protokoll Notiz
in der in dem Beschluss der NPK dazu
dass ein Land gesagt hätte wir machen da
nicht mit oder sehen das